hello everyone so I'm let that created
public speaking as Sara I working I'm
working as a partner development manager
for the partners that are based in
Central Europe and Russia I'm managing
clerics outfit seven Lord current and
many other guys you know every time I
have to do such a presentation I'm like
okay I hope that the next round at least
is not coming anytime soon
and I'm not talking only about late I'll
but then when I'm offered with the
possibility I accept the challenge
one of the reasons because I like she
like competing with myself and we all
know that actually if you inside someone
by creating like a challenge for him he
is more likely to participate this is
why she's the presentation is called
there is a competitor in every person in
every player and we know that we are
managing players when you actually think
about it you know that the humanity and
people were always competitive right we
always try to take part in different
contest tournaments wars actually even
the video games by their nature they are
pretty competitive product there is a
change in every game they're just all
different so today I will talk about
what do we mean by competitive gaming
which is a bit more than just finishing
a different level then we'll see how you
can make your game more competitive
we'll go through three cases is
something wrong with the text or no
we'll go through three case of features
let's say modes that were added to games
by our partners many of them are in the
room thank you very much for sharing us
the cases with us every time it's really
helpful
well then we'll check three games that
are very competitive by their nature
here we have actually some nice stars
and guns and shooting
- have it on this pours because this is
like in everyone's mind wrap up the
presentation and give you the time to
ask questions if you have it so
competitive gaming as I just mentioned
how is it different in our mind than
just finishing a different level so for
us it's it's something that is of a more
involved form of gaming that is a part
of your game that includes the success
the progress measurement and the
recognition from your game design and in
many cases prizes right
we know that the computed gaming is
actually coming on mobile from PC PC
it's still a good example for many of
our titles it's still the most lasting
platform in time with the most bread
games run still the one that brings the
most revenue it still have a premium and
premium distribution model right we have
a lot of hardcore titles that are just
being sold without having any
subscription or in Apps plans we know
that the popularity of competitive games
is still growing on whether they're just
hardcore titles or on whether they are
part of the eSports like League of
Legends and Altos and we know that
thanks to the strong word-of-mouth
factor those games are very popular so
this is what helping now if we compare
it on mobile what we have we know that
this trend is growing but it this trend
is having some challenges they are all
listed here first of all because the
biggest majority of competitive game is
a free-to-play mobile it's pretty hard
to balance your customer spend and the
feeling that you are achieving something
right the equal chances to win the form
factor touch controls pretty hard to
make them really handy in competitive
Network issues not always you know the
best connection to to make you feel very
immersed in your game the games runners
not always available not all the types
of games
available on mobile games and every
session lengths right depending on the
games runner is pretty short so it's
pretty hard to stick someone to your
product we've been talking about
retention all these changes that you
guys have in general however when we
talk about competing gaming we all know
that the level of mastery is something
that counts a lot the more the player
feels that he's managing the processes
the the game the more he is engaged in
fact for us and in this case this is a
synonym so well brain install
brainstorming about the cognitive gaming
we were actually asking ourselves what
additional features or game modes you
can add to your game to make them more
competitive considering the fact that
they already a competitive product
making something of it is more convivial
less okay then the Captain Obvious jumps
into the room and says that okay yeah
the most hardcore is your title the more
competitive it is so one of the solution
that you have is just simply designing
if you don't have like a project yet a
product that is more hardcore the more
hardcore it is the more competitive it
is thanks mister captain but then if you
already have a product on whether it's
casual or already
mitko hardcore game you can actually
improve it make it more competitive for
the place by adding features here just
it's just a simple slide that goes from
the more soft coercing features that you
can add to your product to the most
hardcore we all know that League ladders
and achievements single PvE missions are
really good they usually actually help
your players discovering the content you
remember they are not developers they
just play your game contests and Co PvE
can be online for the contest offline as
well
co-op Evie there is no engagement this
help place to socialize to have common
goals to achieve then single player and
team player PvP is one of the best
things
you can do to engage your players even
more to make them compete even more and
then when it's a single player or team
player direct pvp because we know that
there are a lot of games account running
I think PvP modes right this is even
more hardcore eSports I'm just putting
it here for the moment because obviously
then people asking why we are not
talking about eSports I will touch him a
bit on that in a Latino and presentation
so those are the modes the features that
you can introduce if you are lacking of
ideas so now I will go through three
cases of features that were added to
casual mid core games by our partners
and see what results it has produced
like kind of case studies right so here
again thank you very much guys for
sharing the information with us we have
three titles one is cooking fever by
Lorde current talking tom gold run by
outfit seven and the nonstop tonight
Bioware games I decided to put the three
products side-by-side because I'm more
focusing on features rather than on game
design we believe that some ideas can be
easily interchangeable between the
products if you want to make them
competitive so what happened is that in
cooking fever the partner has added
tournaments tournaments is a feature
where people have to complete complete a
biggest number of levels and then the
results are being compared to 20
different players in talking Tom gold
run they introduced a PV racing contest
this game is a runner
and in this case instead of running
against just a timer you are running
against a machine and then again your
results have been compared and what
happened in the nonstop light is that
developer introduced at a massive boss
fight event where people have to come in
groups to fight different bosses so they
have to plan accordingly
this feature is a bit more hardcore so
what happened is the end is that
actually all of these changes had a
great impact on
engagement and the increase of the daily
active users and people who would take
part in the tournaments and
demonstration metrics we can see for
example that almost 300,000 people took
place and mode introduced to hopeful
fever and actually 50% of people get
back to it we can actually see that the
impact it had on the revenue was of the
same importance of some hope some live
ups and sales that were conducted in the
game before and I should the developer
has reported that this even can be
regenerated and which time producing the
same effect in talking to Tom don't run
here again very successful case where
the user started playing the game more
actually increasing the average time
spent by one minute it's a lot and they
find the way on how to oblige users to
spend more of the in-game currency I
know that sometimes some of you having
troubles actually with how to wash out
this extra currency that players managed
to accumulate and therefore are not
spending real money anymore in the
nonstop night the results actually were
pretty spectacular the number of daily
active active users has increased a lot
and the daily customer spent has fault
as well so now if we if you actually a
casual game developer and we take the
pros and the cons and the data that we
have seen before we know that going
casual gaming is good because the games
have simple mechanics because they must
appeal low barrier of entry people
understand them easily and they have a
good replay value it's a lot of content
that people can play again but in the
same time you are probably facing
challenges like the fact that they are
pretty easy to copy I'm not listening
that any game can be copied but still
that you are fighting with other
companies that
probably fight for the same customer
players you and low conversion rates so
overall if you help people and players
with bring them more common challenges
socializing better and track all the
progress it should help you increasing
your engagement and metrics overall well
this is at least what our partners have
tried this is in what we believe and
this is what we decided to share with
you okay
so this is for the casual segment next
part is about mitko hardcore gaming and
as I mentioned those three titles I'll
be talking about are really about
competition the game design is
competitive by by nature so first
product is the one that people a lot of
people are currently stirring it because
it's actually popped up from nowhere it
is showing incredible performance and
it's actually a very very cool game
beyond on so called last game honors
zombie PvP slash survivor slash RPG
crafting actually this game has
everything in it and when it was
released and started performing
incredibly it was actually and is still
in the beta stage kind of BT you know
very handy item so actually beta is
important here because when the game was
released four months ago it had only
like 20% of features that the partner
was manage to implement because they
were actually a bit surprised by success
but in the same time having great plans
and just with this 20% of features but
with a good overview of what is coming
next in the game they were able to
obtain incredible results so those are
like the first matrix and actually the
things to thank you the partner never
mind it actually
sharing the full information with us you
will see the actually the next slides
are pretty incredible so currently the
developer is working on the introduction
of these mods that is still not in the
game and they will be actually focusing
a lot on the competition among players
and you can see that we have a good
range of different PvP scenarios pv pv p
co-op scenarios and direct PvP
confrontation so remember that I just
said that only 20% of what was plant was
introduced to the game and this is
actually how the daily active users
curve is behaving right now so this is
like the real data provided by the
developer since the game launched so as
you can see the number of daily active
uses the pretty impressive but what is
actually more impressive this is like
the cherry on the top of the cake is the
revenue that is currently generated by
Android and here again listen actually
the achieve result results there is one
key takeaway that actually I would like
to take from this case this is actually
as I just mentioned it what you actually
show and would you allow allow players
to plan can actually help you a lot in
terms of your father game development
choices even though if you don't have
the time to implement everything that
you have planned try to work with the
community to show them this is colonel
by any means that you have because this
is important because if players they
know that this kind of content is coming
they will gather resources invest their
time and plan accordingly and this helps
you actually engaging them on a longer
term to next cases so during a many
actually years no one dared to make a
true first-person shooter on mobile but
then we actually had an industry veteran
which is not presented on this slide but
somehow came up with a crazy idea I'm
naming a mud fingers and the game called
the dead trigger they decided to put
Auto shooting in first-person shooters
so that we don't have to fight against
your mobile phone every time you have an
enemy in your scope it should
automatically and actually based on that
we have two incredible developers that
made two actually really cool first
first-person shooters and release them
on Android on the Left we have mono
strike was actually a pretty big number
of installs and gums off boom both games
feels differently but they feel very
immersive and they have different
settings the left one feels more like
Counter Strike the right one feels to me
more like team Team Fortress then it
depends on what kind of gay gamer you
are obviously those games as I mentioned
they computed by nature so they already
inciting players who love first-person
shooters coming to mobile it tried them
out but in their current development
stages that both partners have chosen a
slightly slightly different strategies
to keep on working with their community
on one side I see a story there's one
slide missing okay sort of parole
on one side modern strike is keeping on
increasing the deepness of the mastery
of the weapons and the feedback the
players get from the progress they have
in the game whereas on the other side
game inside are focusing a lot on the
work and the feedback they get from the
community they put a big stress on the
tournaments and the interactions the
players might have together how they
compete against each other
besides that actually as I would like to
put a special stress on the whole work
that is being done with the community
actually you have all the channels that
allow you to broadcast your content and
share it with the players that the
partner is currently using the video hub
section is for instance introduced in
the game there is a lot of content that
is being created on daily basis by the
players using YouTube gaming YouTube
overall and popular YouTube bloggers
here again four different focus but good
results footballs while other games are
focusing as I said on the feedback the
players got and the deepness of their
weapons they have pretty decent results
every time they introduce those features
to the game they can be see on the left
while working hard with the community
game inside have something that in my
opinion is very precious nowadays we all
know that the competition is actually
really strong and the user acquisition
are growing but designing a game that
can be promoted throughout that means
then just standard user acquisition
channels and in this case is strong
word-of-mouth and this we mentioned that
was a session before YouTube videos that
in some times actually promote your
product much better than any campaign
that you can design is actually driving
a lot of users to this product making it
overall very successful creating stable
users behave
good retention and overall good revenue
so here again if we do the same exercise
as we did for the casual games we know
that if you haven't decide that you
decided yet to go hardcore you should go
there because and those karmic games
allow you to attract different users
because they are more impressive they
have more complex control schemes they
allow you to add more deepness in the
same time don't forget that you will be
always actually competing with other
platforms as I mentioned at the
beginning of my presentation this is
still the one that is the most hardcore
and that attracts the intention from a
lot of players and then using the
examples that I have just given you can
use those tips to work better with your
community the like the most important
key takeaway is the way you work with
the community I know that on mobile is
pretty hard to move your player from the
gaming process to a forum page or to
wherever else where you have a message
tailored to him however if the players
know that you care about them and you
tell tailor those messages and
constantly work on it they come they
listen to your feedback and they work
with you which allows you actually much
better interactions so never give up and
listen to your community in sharing
information about your plans so yeah we
were talking about competitive gaming
and actually there is a the eSports
subject you know the sports on my pile
reminds me about like flying sources
everyone is talking about them but no
one has ever seen it kind of yeah
so with the challenge for eSports on
mobile first it's a good opportunity we
know according to the super data stats
and actually you don't even need to get
a statistic that this subject has an
enormous outreach potential right there
are a lot of people people who watch too
they take part in to them they watch in
play they are like separated in
different groups but on mobile is it's
not truly effective yet actually I
haven't heard anyone like giving a
proper definition on what is eSport on
mobile so far probably because they've
eSports on mobile have these changes and
need to comply with these things so the
game needs to be free to win right if
you want like to have a true eSport
title it has to be free too well
synchronous battles
I think it's an obvious point actually
if you can make a game that is playable
in team it will be actually a big plus
show certain level of mastery well I
guess we're talking about eSports
so if it's just a casual top title you
cannot make it really any sport title
last in time we know that once you
create a community you have to always
fill it with a new content new plan for
tournaments new prizes and so on so if
your product is not respecting this
point you cannot call it an export item
and one of the most important things is
to get spectators attention because if I
offer you like football tickets to to to
a match of two teams that you have never
heard about it you will probably know go
never go to see the game but if it's
Brazil playing against France and if you
are not even a football fan
you will probably go and see just for
the for the checkbook point so here is
the change with which the mobile game in
my opinion is fighting against is making
sure that the product that you are
designing for being an eSport one is
interesting to watch while being played
from a mobile device if I would stop
here I think I would like leave an empty
spot but he again in my opinion there
are games that already kind of suitable
and respect those rules I came up here
with three examples but actually if we
looked for them we can find more
so those three titles respect all the
rules it can can potentially become true
eSport titles what is also interesting
to know is that we have couple of
developers that are working on titles
that will be really interesting in terms
at least in terms of the computed gaming
I'm not sure on whether they will be
able to put them to a sports level but I
just wanted to share with your own what
is coming actually I'm a gamer myself
and watching into this subject very much
so we have at least two cool titles
coming from wargaming which is one is
World of Tanks a world of warships blitz
it's a big franchise coming we have word
gaming in the road having actually 7 vs.
7 team battles which is pretty
exceptional on mobile and this title
will be very competitive by the way and
warfare this game is actually coming in
starcraft like ish setting having direct
PvP battles which is also kind of cool
and then we actually have two really
exceptional titles won by the veteran
that I mentioned at the very beginning
those guys actually doing an amazing job
in terms of bringing triple-a class
title on mobile where people will be
fighting in a big MMO world and actually
even the most successful PvP players
will get status inside the capital
cities you know as one of the factors to
motivate them and then we have a very
cool Second World War title so what can
I tell more actually you know we've
talked about competition we talked about
eSports and we actually all know that
the augmented reality is really trendy
and here again we have partners that are
doing exceptional work in this term and
actually I wanted to share with you a
video that showcases an ER mode that
allows you to spectate a game matches so
if we can
the video please
[Music]
you're supposed to be remote okay well
so yeah I hope that you were inspired by
this presentation because I believe that
working you know a lot of with figures
and conversions life is a matter of
conversion so if by my speech I
converted you today like to start the
work on a more competitive feature in
your game will get resolved soon and the
hardest part is to to start just to wrap
up this session
those are like in Liping the five most
important points that you should take
away is that it's important to build
computing modes in the game but you have
to choose the level of competition that
depends on the player allowing and as I
said mentioning the progress showing the
progress to your players is very
important players even on mobile like
direct PvP FPS is trendy first-person
shooters there is still some room
because there is less competition but a
big pool of partners are coming when
designing competition features still
bear in mind amenities monetization
because if you increase engagement but
it doesn't have any impact on the way
you monetize your players you will still
have some homework to do and cool game
design and cool game features nowadays
will love you to promote your game
through other channels than just paid
user acquisition so I hope that this was
interesting and now I'm ready to answer
your questions if you have any
you